these are all characters with bounties
over 1 billion berries in one piece as
of the latest chapters of the manga how
they got their respective bouncy and
whether they actually deserve it or not
all the way at the bottom of the list of
the most valuable pirates in one piece
is jack the drought third commander of
the beast pirates jack is a giant
fishman that has eaten the ancient
mammoth zone fruit with incredible
physical power and endurance he's known
for his cruel and brutal methods like
the gas attack and torture that he
conducted on zou the island of the minx
he is fiercely loyal to his captain
kaido and was willing to die for him
during the raid on onigishima where he
took on the elite force of the minks in
their soolong form for both his power
and his brutal nature jack has earned a
bounty of exactly 1 billion berries just
barely making the cut for this exclusive
club of pirates since he got defeated
during the battle for wano and the beast
pirates got captured with the situation
of their captain unknown right now
jack's bouncy might actually be reduced
in the future nonetheless he has proven
to us why he is in the one billion club
just above jack is vinsmoke sanji the
first of four straw hat pirates on this
list and the official cook of the crew
sanji has proven his worth and strength
as a member of the new yonko crew over
and over again he has grown incredibly
strong as a fighter unlocking the
abilities of his vinsmoke dna over the
course of wano on top of his fire
abilities as well he can do skywalk and
has some of the best observation hockey
in the crew he managed to take down
queen kaido's second commander and help
luffy reach the status of yonko this
earned him a bounty of 1 billion and 32
million berries putting him in the top
20 of the highest bounties in the story
which i think is more than justified
next up is charlotte katakuri first
commander of the big mom pirates
katakuri has basically been leading the
yonko crew whenever big mom was going on
one of her hunger tangents like most
first commanders he enjoys incredible
respect throughout the pirate world and
has incredibly advanced observation
hockey abilities so far only shared by
the likes of luffy and kaido that allow
him to look slightly into the future he
has excellent control over his
incredibly powerful devil fruit and
excellent leadership skills his defeat
by luffy was only due to his sense of
honor and his willingness to let luffy
grow and evolve during their fight and
so despite his defeat he is a true force
to be reckoned with and the second
strongest fighter amongst the big man
pirates thus earning him rightfully a 1
billion 57 million barry bouncy with
katakuri in between after sanji we have
two more straw hat pirates in a row
first is jimbei former warlord of the
sea and helmsman of the straw hat
pirates next to jack he is the only
other fishman on this list not only was
jinbe an equal among the likes of mihawk
doflamingo and boa hancock he is also
the most powerful user of the legendary
art of fishman karate that means he's
able to use and manipulate the forces of
the ocean and fight underwater like no
one else this would be a great feat by
itself already but in a world of
powerful devil fruit users who are weak
against seawater he is a truly powerful
weapon for his captain put in the
deepest level of impul down and now part
of emperor luffy's crew jimbei has more
than earned his impressive bounty of 1
billion 100 million berries and just a
little bit ahead of him is another straw
hat luffy's second in command and
contender for the title of the strongest
swordsman in the world roronoa zorro no
one doubts that luffy's right hand man
belongs on this list if anything he
ranks too low here zorro has really been
close to luffy's equal in power
throughout the story not only has he
been acknowledged and trained by the
strongest swordsman in the world dracul
mihawk
but he also is a yielder of conquerors
hockey zorro has been growing stronger
and more terrifying as a fighter
throughout the entire story always
willing to sacrifice his life for his
honor as a swordsman and the safety of
his crew he's fiercely loyal to luffy
and closely resembles the relationship
between silva's rayleigh and gold roger
after literally escaping death cutting
kaido the strongest creature in the
world and taking down king zorro has
more than earned his 1 billion
111 million barry bouncy now making a
bit of a jump of over 200 million
berries we have the three remaining
yonko commanders on this list starting
out with queen the plague second
commander of the beast pirates like
everyone else in the higher echelons of
the crew queen also wields a powerful
ancient zone devil fruit that they have
modified with cyborg technology not only
are they an incredibly powerful fighter
but they also have incredible
technological and scientific knowledge
on the level of sanji's father judge
vinsmoke or caesar clown he's known for
his love of torture and cruelty however
he has been portrayed as a more comedic
character throughout the wanokuni arc
and so maybe his bounty is a little bit
high but his 1 billion 320 million
berries are still sort of reasonable i
think on rank 15 we have one of the
coolest characters of the story with one
of the best devil fruits marco the
phoenix first commander and doctor of
the whitebeard pirates marco has fought
against the most powerful people in the
one piece world and always made it out
alive and with little to no damage he
fought the admirals at marineford
blackbeard and his men during the
payback war and of course big mom as
well as kaido's commanders and i mean we
don't even know who else he might have
fought over the course of his career
marco is not only incredibly smart but
has probably the most useful devil fruit
in the entire story his mythical phoenix
fruit that gives him not only great
attacking power and the ability to fly
but also gives him the properties of a
logia fruit and strong healing abilities
just like a phoenix marco seems almost
impossible to kill and is able to heal
large groups of people during battle as
he proved during the battle on igashima
if anything his 1 billion 374 million
barry bounty almost seems too low for
being honest especially since one place
above him sits king who faced off
against marco together with queen
nonetheless he of course deserves a
place on this list as well he is kaido's
right hand man after all a swordsman who
has also eaten a winged ancient devil
fruit this is almost a little bit wasted
on king however as he has wings of his
own as possibly the last surviving
member of the lunarian race the former
gods who lived on top of the red line
king possesses incredible powers
including the ability to naturally
generate fire and so while he just
barely lost to zara during wano it's not
really hard to see how this man who
stood side by side with kaido would have
gotten his 1 billion 390 million barry
bounty and so with this the remaining
characters in this list are part of one
out of three groups former warlords part
of the worst generation or a yonko
starting with plays 13 and the pirate
empress boa hancock hancock not only is
the leader of the cuja pirates a tribe
of legendary female warriors living on
amazon lily but she also is one of the
few confirmed people who can use
conquerors hockey on top of that she
wields one of the most powerful devil
fruits in the entire story that is able
to turn anyone with strong emotions for
her into stone an ability so powerful
that blackbeard wanted to get his hands
on it no matter what hancock has held
herself against a number of powerful
enemies and survived the horrors of
slavery at the hands of the celestial
dragons with the warlord system now
abolished her new
1659 million barry bounty shows just how
powerful luffy's self-declared future
wife truly is next in line is another
former world of the sea that has just
made his comeback into the story sir
crocodile founder and commander of the
newly founded cross guild organization
crocodile not only managed to bring an
entire country under his control in
alabasta but he's also experienced in
leading powerful organizations like the
baroque works together with nico robin
and now an even more powerful one
together with dracul mihawk to his
credit crocodile was not afraid to face
whitebeard or kainu during the
marineford war and apparently has grown
a lot stronger his new bounty of 1
billion 965 million berries seems quite
high admittedly considering that he lost
to a luffy with no hockey but i'm
nonetheless quite excited for him to
show us why he deserves the 12th highest
bounty in the entire story now however
we not only break into the top 10 of the
list but we also make a jump of over 1
billion berries into the three billions
because sharing places 9 10 and 11 are
three members of the worst generation
all with exactly 3 billion berries
monkey d luffy trafalgar d law and
eustace captain kits these three were
already portrayed as rivals and roughly
equals during the saba odi archipelago
arc now the trio has teamed up to take
down two of the former empress big mom
and kaido kit has an incredibly powerful
magnet devil fruit ability combined with
a crazy bloodlust a darker version of
luffy really that was able to stand his
ground against the yonko with his brute
force he even tried attacking shanks
before where he lost an arm and has only
been growing stronger ever since la
meanwhile has one of the if not the most
valuable devil fruit there is the oppe
opinomi that not only has incredible
fighting abilities but that also is
capable of granting immortality law is
incredibly intelligent and really shines
as a supporting fighter in combination
with a brawler-like type like luffy or
kitts i personally do find that both of
their bounties are a little bit too high
yes they took down big mom and i
understand that achieva wants to
underline the rivalry between all three
of the captains but i still think that a
bounty slightly below luffy would have
been more reasonable here after all
luffy did fight kaido alone while these
two teamed up nonetheless they do belong
on this list without any question now
luffy on the other hand as the captain
of the straw hat pirates and protagonist
of the story has been earning his bounty
from day one he has changed the
one-piece world like almost no one else
he has taken down the most powerful
creature in the world and awakened his
legendary sun god devil fruit during
this fight a fruit by the way feared so
much by the world government that they
tried to erase its true nature and name
from history luffy has some of the most
powerful abilities in the story and is
no longer considered as an underdog but
a serious contender for the pirate king
crown by the entire world at this point
slightly ahead of luffy is the other new
emperor the great jester buggy the clown
buggy is a real wildcat in the story in
a number of ways he has failed his way
up so much you can't really help but
wonder if he's not some secret genius
that is orchestrating things from behind
the scenes however at least of right now
buggy is really a nobody who has light
and tricked his way by accident into a
position that he doesn't even want to be
in at the mercy of crocodile and mihawk
as the official leader of the cross
guild organization in the end buggy's
real bounty should probably be either 10
million berries or 10 billion berries so
only time will tell which one it is for
now at least the buggy sits at 3 billion
189 million berries his commander and
strongest member of the cross guild
organization is only one rank above him
the marine hunter and strongest
swordsman in the world dracul mihawk
mihawk without any doubt is one of the
strongest 10 characters in the entire
story he's able to fight with basically
anyone and might have been able to
become a yonko himself
if buggy didn't steal the spotlight by
accident mioc has had legendary duels
with shanks and even surpassed him in
his swordsman skills he is sure to have
extremely powerful haki demonstrated by
his supreme great sword yoru that he
turned into a black blade now mihawk
just like buggy is a bit of a wild card
in his own regard too and whoever ends
up having him as an ally will be a true
force to be reckoned with rightly so his
new bounty after the abolishment of the
warlord system are a proud 3 billion
590 million berries then barely missing
the top 5 and the club of 4 million
barry bounties is the third current
emperor of the sea and most likely
luffy's biggest rival for the throne of
pirate king
marshall d teach aka blackbeard teach on
purpose has laid low for years stayed
under the radar and carefully has been
planning his new very quick rise to
power he has assembled a crew of the
most dangerous and powerful pirates in
the world has started hunting devil
fruits for his crew and is the only
known person in the story so far who has
successfully eaten two devil fruits as
one of the biggest threats and most
dangerous people on the planet right now
teach rightfully has gained a new bounty
of 3 billion
996 million berries also here are a few
characters that might be somewhere on
this list too but whose bounty we don't
know quite yet so israeli rox diese beck
shanks's admirals blackbeard's admirals
monkey d dragon and the golden lion
shiki which now brings us to the top 5
highest known bounties in one piece and
your chance to quickly subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already because
you're awesome just as awesome as the
number five and probably most legendary
character in the entire series the
captain of the red hair pirates and last
remaining yonko of the original four red
hair shanks shanks has been a very big
mystery for the longest time in the
story and to a certain degree still is
however we now at least know that he
isn't an emperor for nothing as a former
member of the roger pirates that has
grown up on the pirate king's ship he
has spent his entire life training and
fighting by the sight of the strongest
people in the world as far as we know he
has the strongest hockey in the entire
series with next level abilities that
allow him to cancel out other people's
haki and a presence that can even stun a
marine admiral he also is a master
swordsman and on top of that he has also
enormous political power and connections
second to no other pirates all of that
without ever having eaten a devil fruit
or even having a single devil fruit user
in his crew rightfully so shanks has a
bounty of 4 billion 48 million 900 000
berries which is probably even too low
if we're being honest now the next three
places are all being held by former
rocks pirates just a little bit above
shanks and probably due to her longer
time as a yonko is big mom big mom is a
true force of nature not only she
practically indestructible she also
wields one of the most terrifying devil
fruits that allows soul manipulation she
has a crew of powerful children of hers
and is a master in intel gathering and
political maneuvering even though she
has now been taken down for decades she
was the strongest woman in the entire
one piece world with a 4 billion
388 million barry bounty in third place
is her former crewmate and later ally
the strongest creature in the world
kaido another true force of nature and
gigantic size seemingly invincible with
a mythical dragonzone devil fruit that
made his powers even more ridiculous
than they already were kaido was feared
and respected by everyone his presence
alone was enough to keep any other yonko
or the government from interfering in
his affairs in wano he was convinced
that he could change the world and bring
about the return of joy boy which
ultimately he did even if he was a
terrible person doing it his brutal
methods and colossal power put him above
big mom at 4 billion
611 million 100 000 berries which now
leaves us with the two highest bounties
in the story number two is edward
newgate aka whitebeard the former
strongest man in the world with 5
billion
46 million berries and naturally the
only person above him is of course the
first pirate king goldie roger only
because he found the last island and
learned the true history these two
pirates were at the pinnacle of an
entire era two absolute legends the
strongest and most influential pirates
in the story so far roger with the
number one bounty of five billion five
hundred sixty four million eight hundred
thousand berries and so the real
question now is who will surpass these
two well two very likely candidates are
luffy and shanks and if you want to know
why well you should really not miss out
on this video right here